break down your relationship status and
how you're making your money and believe
me expand upon that a little bit if you
will okay well
i'm not gonna go into super specific
detail with the relationship stuff but
let's just say i'm in
multiple relationships
right now okay uh multiple relationships
that might be news for any of those
girls who are listening
right now there's somebody's out there
in my fitness i don't i don't lie to
them i tell them i'm not exclusive to
them straight up they know that they're
of course they're exclusive to me
yes they're like they're like they know
that yeah they know that
yeah
they accept that deal when they they met
you the first time so they're my girls
they don't see anybody else yeah mine uh
you know i'm looking at
i'm thinking about starting a family
with a couple of them and then there's a
couple of them in the next year separate
families or all together separate at the
moment okay my grand plan if i'm going
to go into detail my grand plan
is to move all of my families together
in one big property and have like sister
wives bingo sister wives that's exactly
that's the correct time we're going to
see you on tv in a different way i don't
know maybe sister wives okay
yeah that's that's that's the current
situation and they're basically in
different
countries all around the world gotcha
right now so how many in south florida
and south florida there's no wives here
no waves there's no wives no wacky
potential down here not in miami man
straight up you ain't you ain't finding
a wife in miami wow
this is not my problem i've lived here
my entire life 41 years now yeah
i think they'll tell you like perfect
i've lived in miami now for about a year
and a half yep
like
i go to europe for like two weeks i have
a girlfriend
and she's and she's sticking around for
like a year without me even seeing her
how do you think that though why why do
you think why do i think which part like
why do you think when you go out there
you can find a girlfriend like that and
now tears i think that
in eastern europe the culture is very
very different
okay
in eastern europe for example
a girl is looking for a husband
she's looking
to commit to somebody and and they're
pretty based out there like a romanian
girl she knows that if okay if a dude's
worth his salt if a guy's making some
decent money he's probably going to be
screwing around a bit yeah behind her
that comes with the territory it comes
with the territory it's like expected
out there yeah like they you know they
they used to like
mafia bosses and stuff like that so it's
like okay a guy comes around a bit of
money
all right
as long as he takes care of me
i don't care that he's seen some hoe on
the side
they don't care
which is the main one oh yeah as long as
she's interested
out of your girls do they know do they
all think they're the main
let's just leave that
you're gonna get started
what are you doing and then uh sterling
career-wise where are you at right now
financially what are you focusing on how
are you making your money so nowadays
most of my money is made through my
info products you could say so the
advice i give out for free on youtube
and stuff i also have a bunch of
products i sell that help guys overcome
all the different problems they face in
the bedroom like performance anxiety
premature ejaculation teaching them how
to lay properly teaching them how to get
their girl off how to make them squirt
how to make them orgasm all this sort of
stuff uh
yeah that's my primary
income stream right now i also dabble in
crypto i also run uh only fans accounts
for girls so that's another secret
stream of income i have four women yeah
i run their accounts for them okay yeah
so there's a there's a few different
sources right now so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire
saucecast click right here
you